we're back with my nearest and dearest
cameron diaz and lucy lou so we grew
and we grew up and now
we are moms do you think you're a
different person now
lucy than you were then like aside from
us knowing each other and our friendship
just
you as a human i think in my 20s i felt
very
bulletproof and very
you know i don't want to say it was
risk-taking because it was beyond that
it was like i didn't really care if i
lived or died
you know i just didn't and i lost my
father a few years ago and
i didn't really recognize the levels
that we have
in our lives and you know like he was a
place
in my in my life that was always sort of
a
kind of a a roof you know and so
suddenly you feel like the
the roof has been torn off and then you
sort of recognize
oh you know i am now the roof you know
and i happen to have a child
so i guess i'm the roof to that child so
now i really have to understand that i
have to shelter him
and i have to show i'm i have a
responsibility and it's
it's a very powerful thing it's also
terrifying
if i think about it i think my heart was
smaller back then because was sort of
more
inclined to what i wanted to do but now
it's sort of like what do we want to do
and it feels
it feels good because i feel like a
fuller person
like life seems much more you know
kind of colorful and wild because
there's so many more opportunities as a
mom
to kind of like discover and you know
there's so much more curiosity with kids
and it's sort of
it's mind-blowing and it's actually more
terrifying in a way you know because
you're also responsible for this little
person
highest stakes so it's like oh my god i
thought i was on a
riot you know a ride back then a wild
ride but actually it's now that it's
even more intense well you nailed it
because you're just dealing with your
own mortality
and all of the sudden when you have a
kid i don't care if it sounds
codependent my kids
are more meaningful to me than my own
life i think there's something that
in our dna that it gets triggered you
know like that just clicks on
um when you're you become a parent
you have to to make sure that they they
survive
they have to they go on you we will die
i'm sorry to get like morbid and this is
those times when drew goes
really you're going to die do we have to
talk about that
for your first show it's all about
mortality i know i'm
i'm no longer a young idiot who thinks i
am immortal which i'm glad to know i'm
not i wasn't the only one
i mean i hurled myself around i abused
this carcass to no end
and i just thought true i was going to
die young so who cares live now and go
for it
and now yeah i mean 2020 will make you
think about your mortality children will
make you think about mario mortality you
know in my 20s it was just sort of like
here we go yeah all right jump on that
gotcha oh is that a wild horse oh cool
yeah no i know how to hold on for my
life
let's go you know there's such a
liberation
in that too though you know and yeah so
glad i did it all
when i thought about trying to
accomplish something big
in my life at another point you two were
the people i did it with
and so of course what a natural fit
that you're the two people that came
into my head in my heart when i thought
how would i like to honor this endeavor
i see myself with you guys
exactly what the world needs they need
your light they need your joyousness
they need your perspective
what one of the things that i have
always been in total awe of
in you is your ability to like take in
all the information how quick you are to
not just like
what's in front of you but like the
nuances and the
the sort of the humanity and intellect
you can
you read more books than any person i
know you
uh you listen to more music you um
look at more art you bring you watch
more television and film you're actually
taking in all the information and you're
synthesizing it
and you're bringing it into this really
unique perspective
that is all about how it like connects
all of us together
even if it doesn't feel like it has
anything to do with one another
and you bring it to the world in this
joyous beautiful
like buoyant light that is you
and you give it's it's a gift it's like
a truly a gift that you give the world
and you're gonna make the world
a happier better place by giving us that
gift
you have a big soul and a big heart and
doing this show is really special and
wonderful because
you have something to share and you have
gone through tough times in your life
you've had issues with your family
you've had issues with you know
like marriages divorces you have
something to share and i don't know that
i can say that about a lot of things
i've never been married i've never been
endorsed i haven't done a lot of things
that you have so
to me the experience that you have and
that you have to share is exciting and i
think
that you should feel free to do that
because that's who you are you're very
open
generous person i asked you guys here so
i could honor you today
that's what this was about for me yeah
but you can't honor us without us
honoring you that this
is the symbiotic relationship and you
have to be able to give and take and
understand that
a lot of times when i give up like a
friend a compliment
they can't take it you know and like
it's we have it's time for us to receive
well as you said at one of my weddings
when you read the e e cummings poem i
carry your heart
in my heart and i carry both of you and
my heart
i always have i always will thank you
um thank you thank you
and thank you and just say to you
and to thank you
listen man i'm gonna be
thinking tonight in my bed wondering
how i got so lucky
to like live a life with you guys
thank you more than words can ever say
can't wait to see the rest of the season
we're going to celebrate a lot of things
here on this show and friendship is
certainly one of them